hey Vsauce Michael here and when you die
what happens to your body it can be
buried or cremated or donated to science
but are those your only options I mean
what if I wanted to be taxidermied like
my friend here what if I requested to
have my body stuffed and mounted in some
hilarious position like a permanent
high-five so people could high-five my
actual skin forever well it turns out to
be quite complicated so let's begin with
an easier and more flexible solution
cremation and ashes twelve humans have
walked on the moon but 300 humans have
been buried in outer space with the
right connections and budget you can
have a portion of your ashes launched
into space the very first space burial
occurred in 1997 when a rocket deposited
the ashes of 24 people into orbit around
Earth in 1999 human remains were first
buried on the moon a lunar prospector
probe dropped some scientific
instruments and some of the cremated
remains of Eugene shoemaker
co-discoverer of the comet
shoemaker-levy 9 but the first human to
have their remains leave our solar
system will be clyde tombaugh the guy
who discovered Pluto in 2006 some of his
ashes were launched aboard the new
Horizons probe which will arrive near
Pluto in 2015
take some recordings and pictures and
then continue on beyond our solar system
you don't need to get all outer-spacey
to have fun with your ashes right here
on earth there are companies that will
take carbon from your remains and expose
them to extreme heat and pressure long
enough that you wind up with a diamond
made out of you it can be cut and
polished one woman even had it done with
the ashes of meowy her cat
the point here is that you can be quite
creative with cremated remains but ashes
don't look like you did when you were
alive
so let's revisit taxidermy these shapes
and combinations that animals have been
taxidermied into are quite creative
for instance an actual pig turned into
an actual piggy bank a bird light
fixture a goat that's also a bagpipe
doves turned into shoes and of course
the guy who taxidermied his cat into a
remote-controlled quadcopter taxidermy
doesn't preserve every part of your body
it is taxidermy the arrangement of skin
which is okay
I mean taxidermy won't bother to
preserve all of your internal organs but
your skin is your largest organ your
skin comprises anywhere from 12 to 15
percent of your total body weight plus
it's an organ that people see and
recognize you buy but here's one of the
problems when animals are taxidermied
their skin is removed and then mounted
on a mannequin a shape that resembles
the animal but is made of wood or wool
and wire or foam that's fine for museums
but the use of a generic mannequin can
lead to an animal that looks generic all
of the tiny subtle but very important
features of the animal's cartilage fat
muscles are more difficult to recreate
after it's dead and all you have is its
skin that's why many taxidermists
hesitate to taxidermy a person's beloved
pet because in order to satisfy the
client an immense amount of specificity
is required even more so if you were
trying to recreate a person so taxidermy
may not be the best way to preserve
yourself or your daddy or your mummy
mummies
what about them well let's go back to
the 19th century and jeremy bentham when
he died the philosopher requested that
his body be mummified as best as
technology would allow and his body
dressed up in clothes and displayed at
the University College of London it
periodically still is but the
mummification didn't turn out perfectly
so he's really just a skeleton dressed
up and close and stuffed the head wound
up looking a bit too wrinkled and the
colour was off and so a wax head was
made you can check out a 3d photograph
of Jeremy Bentham online and who could
forget the dried-out mummified middle
finger of Galileo we still have it and
it's on display in Florence it's a great
thing to visit if you want a pivotal
historical figure to flip you off but
we're looking for a way to preserve
ourselves realistically as we appear
while living so let's take a look at
embalming not all corpses are embalmed
before they're buried but embalming is a
great technique for preserving a body
slowing down decomposition so it can
stay above ground and be displayed a
little bit longer now if a body is
embalmed really really well it can be
preserved longer than you might think
Abraham Lincoln was embalmed so well
that even though his coffin has been
moved 17 times since he was buried and
the casket opened five times on each of
those occasions including the most
recent in 1901 people said yep still
looks like Lincoln on an even more
extreme scale are the bodies of people
like Mao and linen which continue to be
on display to this day the bodies
require special treatments multiple
times a week the exact techniques and
embalming fluids used to preserve linen
are kept secret but they've kept him
preserved for more than 80 years well
embalmed bodies can be displayed before
being buried in more positions than just
lying down in a coffin for instance
leaned up against a wall
or riding a motorcycle Wow
but embalming doesn't last forever and
if you try to make it last forever be
prepared to spend a lot of money and
time one method that could be used on
humans and has become popular with pets
is similar to instant coffee
freeze-drying the process involves
freezing the animal so that all of its
water solidifies and then using a
partial vacuum with the pressure so low
that the solid water instantly turns
into vapor and escapes away leaving a
much much lighter freeze-dried pet
unfortunately when it comes to
preserving a human body as realistically
as possible after death these methods
freeze drying mummification taxidermy
long term and bombing are either
unsatisfactory or impractical with the
exception possibly of a slightly newer
method plastination it's the method used
to prepare bodies for exhibits like Body
Worlds essentially plastination involves
a specimen soaked in a volatile solvent
and then placed in a polymer solution in
a low-pressure environment the volatile
solvent leaves the specimen and the
empty space is filled with the polymer
solution the specimen is flexible and
can be put into a pose and then the
polymer hardened by using special gases
human bodies that have been plastinated
last a very long time even at room
temperature but here's the crazy thing
it's free you can quite easily donate
your body to the Institute for
plastination it counts as donating your
body to science but here's the thing you
won't necessarily have control over
what's done with
body because at the end of the day
corpses are legally not property no one
owns a corpse because a corpse is not
legally a piece of property no one can
just do whatever they want with it your
options are severely limited and even if
you specifically have requested say that
your body be taxidermied and all of your
surviving can agree and want it to
happen it's very unlikely that a
mortuary would allow that to happen and
historically the law sides with the
mortuary for example in 1994 David
Eugene Russell requested that when he
died his body be skinned his skin tanned
into leather and that leather used to
bind a book of his writings he wanted
this to happen as did his surviving
widow but the mortuary refused to do it
and the court sided with the mortuary so
even if you have a really cool idea for
how your body could be embalmed forever
and displayed in a funny weird or
bizarre way you're not going to get
permission to do so plastination winds
up being one of your only options but
you won't have a lot of control over
what happens to you once plastinated but
hold on a second in 1998 Anthony Noel
Kelly was arrested for stealing
anatomical specimens from the Royal
College of Surgeons now he claimed that
he was not guilty of theft because a
corpse is not a piece of property he was
merely guilty of the mistreatment of a
corpse
but the judge ruled that because these
anatomical specimens had been especially
prepared by licensed and skilled workers
at the college they had become property
so here's something really strange
if you found a way to get your body
taxidermied for the benefit of medical
science in doing so you may actually
become a piece of ownable property so in
a way being taxidermied may be the best
way to allow your survivors your loved
ones to legally and literally to have
you forever and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]